tous les super héros sont animés par un
seul but sauver ceux qui en ont besoin
et ils ont une autre chose en commun
on me les croise jamais dans le monde
réel sophie lee
tous les super-héros une mission dans ce
monde
ne le voit pas toujours tout de suite
parce qu'on ne sait pas toujours où
regarder
flora qu'est ce que c'est que ça je suis
ulysse revenu à l'aise sacrément d'une
manifestation inattendu c'est toi qui a
écrit ça c'est un super héros en quoi
tu as des ennemis toi
je viens pour l'écureuil tu sais le
danger se cachent partout
vival
le lis nous a ouvert les yeux
[Musique]
le monde est rempli de magie et de
merveilles
enfin ici
appuie maintenant pour aller quoi liste
même dans les heures les plus sombres un
véritable héros sera prêts à tout
risquer pour sauver le monde qu'il aime
est-ce que tu parles
ouais d'accord c'est pas tout à fait ça
mais si c'est moi